what's the favorite thing about these
ladies down here how much you're
pounding yeah I like to get on top and
just [ __ ] your [ __ ] up
bottom line all right Bob Bob Brady from
original Los Angeles LA and tell me
about your childhood you grew up with a
both your oh no my parents emigrated
from Soviet Union and I have two younger
sisters but you had a normal childhood I
had a rough childhood how's that
my father emigrated for the Soviet Union
he was a boxer he was in Germany he
escaped and he was a KGB agent Wow he
was the mayor of the city in the Soviet
Union champion chess player and a
playboy and he used to beat my mother up
a lot oh man I witnessed him being
hidden her and she knocked down and
blood came out of her mouth she would
get back up and he knock her again
and she would fall down at typical box
or he liked to drink Slits beer mm-hmm
and any of yous for you as well yes he
used to beat me with a plunger and a
belt what careers what job did he have I
was well that after I delivered the LA
Times I went to school and I became a
eventually I became one of the youngest
officers appointing Bank of America's
history of my 20s I worked at Bank Bank
of America at 525 South Flower Street
and branch 600 at that time it's no
longer there now yeah and so that was
that was the majority of your career was
yes a banker and then after that I
married my first wife Diana and that
didn't go well I ended up in a mental
ward and then I met my second wife that
I married and done Genoa Italy and I
went the divorce with her to end up in a
mental ward and now I'm single on free I
don't have a ring my ring finger and I'm
single free and I'm happy to be alive
and I
life and I live it to the fullest I I
live it to the fullest like I believe in
God give me God take it and I believe
that to tell the truth is all-new truth
and I'm sorry so you'd like to pick up
some of the girls down here and I do we
have party we you know I give them money
so that it could take care of themselves
yeah and you know I right now I just
smoke cigarettes and cigars and I drink
fluids
I'm drug-free alcohol-free if you take
my blood now I have no easily good drugs
in my system but you and I believe that
we all believe the same color so I
respect all citizens nationalities
religion creates and all the love yeah
so you you've had drug and alcohol
problems yes I did my main choice was
cocaine mm-hmm
but your honor I haven't done that in a
long time that's great when you how
often do you come down here to pick up
some of those ladies Oh
when they run into me I hope I'm not
like you do as I say you know you want
to come over and party so are there
other girls
other than Vicki that you yes you have
fun girls ladies women yeah yeah exactly
women she's all ones like yes she is and
how often will you come down here to do
this I live at the Lincoln hotel and I
run into them periodically and I have
phone numbers for all kinds of people
and contacts for because of people yeah
and it's hard to trust who's who so
you'll come down here pick up from the
girls on weekends oh yeah they come to
my like Vicki like you so come and so
I'll come down and let her up like I did
this morning and she told me about you
and and so so you'll have intercourse or
I know we're sir never intercourse
okay just yeah you know private yeah
encounter safe sex yeah I think it's and
there's other persons that I have
instrument relationships like tisha I
either [ __ ] out and what about someone
sexually all no I don't I'm HIV
undetectable yeah and I don't have AIDS
I'd say my medicine no haz undetectable
means what that means I can't pass along
so you have it I have yes
doc magic sauce okay he came out with
AIDS now he's on the where do you think
he got that I was raped years ago and on
the apartment building on the second
floor on the corner of Broadway and
century Boulevard and I woke up one
morning and he was sucking my [ __ ] he's
French Francois like and he was sucking
my [ __ ] and I wanted to [ __ ] him up and
I wanted to kill him and all of a sudden
I realized that I was high if I would
have killed him I would have gone to
jail or prison and I'd let it go and I
went to downtown so I'm in oil and I saw
my psychiatrist and she said you might
want to have your eyes examined said why
she said for aids so I went to primary
care physician and that time elder
Christian L Center Joshua is also known
as and they took a blood test and and I
I went for the results he said I have
some bad news for you and I said what's
that
he said you're HIV infected and you need
medicine so I was taking all kinds of
the medicine for HIV and I went to 826
west on 4th Street South Central LA
picked up my phone called my younger
sister Tanya she did 20 years in the
Army and I told her she was the first
person I told that I was infected with
HIV so anyway it's a new day and I have
a younger sister younger dinner in
Phoenix Arizona and that plan of visit
her next month
so then well cool yeah you seem healthy
yeah I uh I lose you wait we stay on an
even keel I have a sponsor for
alcoholism and for any known ester care
is yeah I'm a man and his name is Donald
he also lives at the Lincoln all telling
the third floor as a matter of fact I
have a meeting tonight eight o'clock
excellent psychotics Anonymous meeting I
went to a lot of AAA beatings any
meetings I got the chitlin [ __ ] and I
plan on keep going to meetings
I believe they're 12 steps and I have a
Bible that I read daily excellent yeah
you don't good job getting away from a
lot of these you know weed out all the
bad people for my life okay so you've
been married a couple times do you have
maybe married a couple times I'm looking
for a third wife and I believe the third
one's a charm
do you enjoy or prefer these kind of
free relationships where you're no I
don't you got to be settled down I would
I think I'm gonna meet someone in church
so your relationship with the ladies
that you pick up is your tonic you treat
them nicely I do I'll Wine and Dine them
and I treat them with the best of my
ability and yeah because a lot of girls
have told me stories about yeah guys
getting broth and all that kind of thing
well you know what you can tell
something to somebody but if they don't
have a good memory or they're high at
the time they could twist it until a
different version of what happened and
that's where you could get mixed up with
your favorite thing about picking up
some of the girls here on most Wine and
Dine them and having sex but what's your
favorite aspect of what's a favorite
thing about these ladies down here I
like to pound them yes I like to get on
top and just [ __ ] your [ __ ] up bottom
line that's what my father do to my
mother he was a Playboy
like I said and my mother lived to be 83
my father would be 72 I'm 61 I'll be 60
to July 12 1952 all right Bobby
well thank you so much for talking to me
being so open are you welcome or thank
you you all have a great rest of the day
and see when I see you talk to you want
all right thank you you're welcome
you